[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
on dirait comme chaque jour de la
semaine pour points de vue autour d'eux
deux analystes
affûté de la situation politique
française bonsoir nicolas baverez
bonsoir vous êtes et céistes avocat
éditorialiste au figaro
vous signez une chronique passionnante
elles le sont par principe mais
spécialement cette semaine parce que
c'est un sujet qu'on traite peu sur la
grande misère de la psychiatrie
française
oui pas les filles ans et c'est un
article il ya pas mal des coûts
précisément je crois c'est un sujet qui
tient à coeur de beaucoup de d'entre
nous d'ailleurs
on sous-estimé l'importance des maladies
mentales dans notre pays en fait elle
touche un français sur cinq
elles sont très mal prise en charge et
donc je pense que ça vaut la peine
d'appeler l'attention dessus et
d'essayer de proposer quelques quelques
solutions pour améliorer la situation
seulement et vous est aussi l'auteur
c'est votre dernier livre car vous en
avez à écrire nombre important
l'alertent démocratique c'est aussi un
observatoire
bonsoir alexandre ii avec qui vous êtes
responsable des pages débats du figaro
magazine c'est aussi en charge du figaro
vox sur le site du figaro votre dernier
ouvrage recomposition le nouveau monde
populiste a été publié aux éditions du
cerf nous commençons par parler ça vous
surprendra pas de ce jugement prononcé
dans l' affaire dite des écoutes
nicolas sarkozy a été condamné à trois
ans de prison dont un ferme pour
corruption et trafic d'influencé
thierry herzog et gilbert azibert en
gamme ont été condamnés dans cette
affaire le
verdict est considérée par les analystes
comme plutôt sévère il fait réagir dans
le camp politique de nicolas sarkozy
écoutez par exemple valérie boyer elle
est sénatrice l ère des bouches du rhône
alors on sent bien qu'elle ne veut pas
critiquer une décision de justice mais
quand même c'est quelque chose qui me
choque profondément
mais bon depuis et que le parquet
national financé interviennent dans
cette affaire d'écoutés téléphoniques
pour un pacte de corruption corruption
qui est vraisemblable n'a pas eu lieu en
tout cas c'est ce qu'ont plaidé
certains est quelque chose qui va
laisser des traces dans la vie politique
tweet de christian jacob le patron du
parti les républicains il considère que
la peine est disproportionnée et
révélatrice d'un acharnement judiciaire
nicolas baverez je le disais vous êtes
avocat ce que vous avez été surpris par
ce par ce verdict ou est ce que c'est
une façon toujours un petit peu la
loterie entre guillemets non on est
forcément frappé j'allais dire du grand
écart entre la sévérité des peines pour
donc les trois prévenus avec une peine
spécifique pour tirer hier rogge
puisqu'en en plus de trois ans dont un
ferme
il écope de cinq ans d'interdiction
d'exercer son métier d'avocat et donc il
ya un contraste très fort entre la
sévérité de ses peines
et quand même un double problème de
droit un problème sur la procédure parce
que tout ceci n'est fondée que sur des
écoutes qui sont des écoutes dont la
légalité il reste extrêmement douteuse
puisque ça a été menée dans le cadre
d'une enquête préliminaire sans aucun
caractère contradictoire son dû pendant
six ans avec des écoutes dérivantes qui
pose un vrai problème de droit et puis
il ya quand même un problème de fond
c'est que ce que dit la motivation du
jugement
c'est qu'il y aurait un pacte de
corruption qui est fondé sur un faisceau
d'indicés concordants
mais quand des magistrats disent qu'il
ya un faisceau d'indicés concordants ça
veut dire qu'il n'ya pas de preuves donc
avoir des peine aussi sévère sans preuve
c'est un vrai problème pour l'état de
droit et c'est un vrai problème pour la
démocratie
donc qu'est ce qu'on peut dire ensuite
comment est-ce que ça a pu s'expliquer
je crois qu'il ya un 4 4 règlement de
comptes
un règlement de compte des magistrats
avec nicolas sarkozy qui n'est pas neuf
qui va se prolonger avec que la sphère
bygmalion ensuite un règlement de
comptes interne à la magistrature
parce que je crois qu'une dimension qui
a été insuffisamment
mise en lumière c'est que les magistrats
ont été scandalisés qu'on puisse laisser
penser que on pouvait peser sur des
décisions de la cour de cassation
précise et un peu gilbert azibert était
un avocat général à la cour de cassation
et que nicolas sarkozy a été condamné
parce qu'il aurait voulu favoriser la
carrière du libéra cyber en échange
d'informations sur une affaire le
concernant le traité par la même cour de
cassation donc ensuite il ya un
règlement de compte avec entre
magistrats et avocats puisque la peine
de qui frappent tirer herzog est
extravagante puis qu'est ce qu'on lui
reproche
on peut contester la ligne de défense ou
la manière dont ils gèrent rogge a
défendu nicolas sarkozy mais condamner
un avocat pour avoir parlé avec son
client au téléphone
c'est quelque chose d'extravagant du
point de vue des droits de la défense
donc ça pose un problème considérable et
la dernière raison c'est que à la suite
d'un certain de révélations qui ont été
faites notamment dans les colonnes du
point il est certain que chez les
magistrats
il y à l'idée qu'il faut à tout prix
sauver le soldat bnf aujourd'hui le parc
national financier qui a été mis en
cause dans toute une série de dossiers
de la fir fillon jusqu'à cette affaire
sarkozy maintenant avec on l'a vu des
procédures qui sont au moins la
frontière du droit et à mon avis en
dehors du droit comme c'est ces écoutes
dit dérivantes et puis par ailleurs on
sait maintenant qu au sein même de ce
pnf il y a eu des situations
d'opposition de harcèlement de
dénonciation enfin c'est une vraie c'est
une vraie pétaudière
et donc comme cette innovation à tort ou
à raison et défendu par le corps des
magistrats
il ya l'idée que dans une procédure très
symbolique
il fallait venir au secours du pmf donc
quand on regarde le tableau général si
vous voulez il est quand même pas très
brillant comme je le disais du point de
vue du droit c'est une décision qui est
très fragile
pour notre démocratie ça va encore
aggraver le soupçon qu'au-delà de la
vendetta entre les politiques et la
magistrature mais que les deux sont
aussi discrédité pour les citoyens il a
ni l'autre c'est satisfaisant ni pour
les uns ni pour les autres et donc
malheureusement on est toujours dans ce
système où finalement les institutions
de la vème république ont perdu
complètement leur régulation et leur
balancier on a non plus une séparation
des pouvoirs mais une guerre en 30 ce
qui devrait être en pouvoir la justice
et qui est une simple autorité et le
monde politique
et puis on a ce qui est très préoccupant
une justice qui ne s'occupe plus du
droit et que des magistrats qui ont leur
moral et qui souhaite imposer leur moral
est à l'état et à la société
et ça il n'y a pas d'exemple dans
l'histoire que ça se termine bien mais
je vais vous passez la parole alexandre
aurait insisté sur le caractère fort et
grave de ce que vous venez de dire ça
prend le temps plus de relief que tous
les gens qui suivent point de vue et qui
lisent nicolas baverez savent que c'est
un homme plutôt pondéré est totalement
étranger aux querelles politiques et
donc la lace la sévérité de votre propos
je pense qu'en prend que plus de relief
alexandre qu'est ce que vous en avez
pensez vous de ce jugement il faut
souligner à nouveau nicolas baverez a
dit beaucoup posent
que je partage intégralement il a été
très précis on peut on peut préciser
deux choses effectivement là la lourdeur
du jugement
il l'a dit pour tirer un zerg mais aussi
pour nicolas sarkozy 1 en goudron
d'alexandre pour préciser que et thierry
herzog et nicolas sarkozy ont tous les
deux fait appel de ce jugement
oui bien sûr aimé mais très lourd parce
que si on compare avec la pourpre
nicolas sarkozy un an de prison ferme
parce qu on se compare avec jean jacques
urvoas qui a été condamné pour des fins
quasiment identique il avait délivré des
informations à attirer sur arce alors
qu'il était garde des sceaux il a été
condamné à un mois de prison avec sursis
donc c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
pour le coup le pape de corruption
étaient avérés ce qui est encore plus
problématique dans cette affaire c'est
les faveurs qu'aurait pu accorder
nicolas sarkozy il les a pas accordé ils
ont pas il ya une conversation
téléphonique où il évoque cette
possibilité là mais ensuite ça se
traduit pas dans les faits donc elles
sont quand même je vais l'aider
voilà en parlant de gilbert azibert à
thierry herzog son avocat exactement
sauf que azibert n'a pas eu la promotion
qu'il espérait donc on ne juge pas là
sur des faits mais sur des intentions
sur la base d'une conversation
téléphonique qui est sujet à
interprétation et la subjectivité donc
donc voilà pour montrer encore une fois
toute la fragilité
je dirais de ce jugement ensuite je
rejoins ce qu'a dit nicolas baverez moi
c'est une préoccupation que j'ai depuis
longtemps et d'ailleurs vous pouvez
souligné qu'il est particulièrement
sévère parce que souvent quand je parle
de gouvernement des juges
il me trouve bien bien excessive moi je
pense que ça sacré dans une dérive
double dérive
de la justice bon d'abord une dérive
idéologique là je pense que c'est plutôt
ça effectivement il ya une vengeance des
juges l'égard de nicolas sarkozy qui a
un peu bousculé l'institution quand il
était président de la république
on sait aujourd'hui qu'il ya des juges
rouges
je rappelle la sphère du meilleur des
cons un tas de personnalités de droite
étaient brocardés sur le mur du syndicat
de la magistrature dont d'ailleurs
nicolas sarkozy mais aussi une dérive je
dirais plus importante qu'il faut simple
pas directement cette affaire mais qui
est et qui effectivement les juges ont
sont en train de s'ériger en législateur
la justice c'est simplement la bouche de
la loi or il semblerait qu'ils qui
veulent faire la loi
sous des prétextes moreau puisque là je
pense qu'il ya une dimension morale si
la peine est aussi lourde c'est bien
parce que nicolas sarkozy est un ancien
président de la république et cela étant
il faut plus de faire des lois ou faire
des carrières politiques parce que oui
bon on se souvient de des poursuites
contre françois fillon qui avait coupé
net sa campagne présidentielle où il y
avait une ligne par là pour le coup les
jeux s'était immiscé dans la campagne la
campagne électorale est effectivement en
déclenchant une enquête avec une
rapidité qui paraissent incroyables mais
de manière de manière générale il ya
sept
cette dérive là où il ya de plus en plus
de jurisprudence si vous voulez qui font
la loi
pour des raisons idéologiques or je
pense que les politiques doivent faire
la loi et les juges l'appliquer elle
appliquée de la même manière pour tout
citoyen qu'il soit puissant ou pas
et la peine doit pas forcément être plus
sévères quand on est plus puissant donc
là voilà il ya les juges ne sont plus
simplement un contre pouvoir ils veulent
être pouvoir et je couds que cela c'est
le vrai danger pour la démocratie parce
qu'ils n'ont été élus par personne les
internautes qui sont nombreux à
commenter ces décisions de justice sont
globalement d'accord avec vous sur
twitter on vous a posé la question
la justice est-elle trop politique en
france question pose évidemment après
cette condamnation la console wii à 61%
nicole 0,6 sur lefigaro.fr il est
évident que c'est une décision
vengeresse de la part des magistrats
s'est beaucoup trois ans ajoute chardon
bleu sur la base de simples hypothèses
flight 94 c'est une honte sans avoir
assisté au procès je m'attendais à ce
type de verdict
evelyne sur youtube oui la magistrature
a tendance à être de gauche voire
d'extrême gauche eric qui considère
qu'il n'y a rien dans ce dossier comme
preuve
et puis mélomanes toujours sur youtube
sans aimer particulièrement sarkozy il
faut admettre qu'il est certain qu'il
est victime pardon d'un certaine
acharnement
il ya claude sur youtube qui disent
probablement que cette sorte de bémol à
tout ce que je viens d'annoncer comme
commentaire qu'il y a des lois et qu'il
faut les appliquer et puis cette
réaction plus politique de bennett 19
la droite doit tourner la page de
l'époque sarkozy est-ce que vous pensez
que c'était un tournant dans dans la cas
la politique de l'ancien chef de l'état
nicolas baverez on sait que nicolas
sarkozy a laissé entendre
il a dit plus exactement tout à fait
explicitement qu'ils ne referaient pas
de politique active mais ils laissent
entendre qu'ils pourraient être un
recours si nécessité s'en faisait sentir
est ce que c'est encore valable
aujourd'hui
je pense que pour le nicolas sarkozy ce
qu'il faut bien voir c'est que c'est le
début d'une séquence judiciaire qui va
être longue et très nourris puisque
derrière il va y voir le procès
bygmalion qui s'ouvre l'audience ouvre
le 17 mars
et puis on a en toile d'arrière fond
puisque cet été aux rich man le la
sphère du départ dans laquelle il ya eu
ces écoutes
l' affaire dite du financement libyen de
la campagne de 2007
donc c'est vrai que cette séquence va
durer et évidemment
ça ne simplifierait pas une éventuelle
candidature de sa part alors cela dit
avec des politiques comme nicolas
sarkozy le résultat peut toujours être
paradoxal et inattendu c'est à dire que
ça peut à linverse le mettre dans un
état de fureur telles que ils cherchent
à lui aussi à régler ces puisqu'on
j'allais dire puisque les juges font de
la politique avec lui il peut être tenté
d'aller faire de la politique avec les
juges à sa manière et je suis pas
certain que ce soit une bonne chose pour
le pays mais il peut avoir le il peut
avoir la tentation ça c'est ça s'est
assuré et c'est vrai que d'une manière
générale il ya quand même une certaine
asymétrie dans les leaders politiques de
premier plan qui se trouve aujourd'hui
j'allais dire éloigné de la politique
par des décisions de justice
oui ce sont plutôt ceux de droite
alexander vecchio vous pensez que c'est
un tournant dans la carrière de nicolas
sarkozy je suis assez d'accord avec ce
qu'a dit nicolas baverez la bonne
nouvelle j'ai presque envie de dire ce
rêve peut-être qu'il tourne
définitivement de la page que politique
puisque moi je fais partie de se
tripoter su que son bilan après été
totalement convaincante et qu'en plus il
est une espèce de d'autorité comme ça on
surplomb sur la droite qui empêche
finalement la droite de ceux de se
reconstruire
donc je pense que ça pourrait être voilà
j'ai dit ce que je pensais tout à
l'heure de la démocratie pour la droite
pour être bien de ne plus avoir l'ombre
tutélaire de nicolas sarkozy mais
connaissant la psychologie du personnage
je suis pas loin de penser comme nicolas
baverez est ce que ça pourrait le
motiver pour se relancer je pense que
c'est pas du tout le même tempérament
que françois fillon qui s'était mis un
peu sottement entre la main des juges il
faut bien le dire nicolas sarkozy est
beaucoup plus combative et ça pourra
être effectivement un ressort pour lui
donc c'est un tournant
mais pas forcément celui qui attendent
les juges si l'idée c'est de mettre hors
jeu pour la présidentielle eh bien ces
e-mails pour être surpris et pourrait au
contraire le relancer sauf qu'il faut à
rappeler quand même pour la
présidentielle c'est que compte tenu du
calendrier
il n'y aura pas de décisions définitives
puisque toutes les condamnations
éventuelles seront frappées d'appel
parce que là aussi nicolas sarkozy a
fait appel ça mais combien de temps pour
une affaire pour arriver en appel une
affaire de ce type
normalement ces 18 mois à deux ans oui
donc fait il bombarde mais on m'aide et
me voilà donc on est après on est à bout
de présidence et bien je vous propose de
laisser le dernier mot à claudius 15 qui
malgré tout ce que vous avez dit
messieurs sur lefigaro.fr nous affirme
moi je fais confiance à la justice
on change de sujet si vous le voulez
bien
certains pensaient que le confinement
allait avoir un impact favorable sur la
natalité bien sûr quand on est enfermé
chez soi mais on s'occupe comme on peut
de toute évidence ça n'a pas été le cas
regardez les chiffres de du nombre de
naissances en france il y en a eu et 730
milles en 2020 ces treize mille de moins
qu'en 2019 -1 8%
mais surtout ce qui est inquiétant c'est
la tendance de cette courbe qui montre
que ça fait dix ans maintenant que le
nombre de naissances diminue chaque
année
est-ce que c'est grave
alexandre de vécu quand on faisait de
l'histoire et qu'on était plus jeune en
dise est important d'avoir beaucoup
d'habitants parce que c'est important
pour l'armée c'est important pour avoir
des bras dans les usines mais
aujourd'hui à plus d'usiné il n'y a plus
d'armée en tout cas de conscription est
ce que c'est encore un élément essentiel
pour une nation que d'avoir des enfants
mais je crois que c'est extrêmement
c'est un symptôme de quelque chose de
mortifère je crois théoriquement on vous
l'avait rappelé historiquement quand il
ya des périodes de crise là qui plus est
il fallait s'occuper puisqu'on était en
confinement on aurait presque pu penser
qu'ils auraient au sortir de cette crise
alors c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas sorti
qui dure plus longtemps que prévu mais
une forme de baby boom
or c'est le contraire et vous l'avez dit
ça s'inscrit dans une tendance lourde je
crois que jean pierre chevènement
rappelé que les quatre dernières années
on avait perdu 50 mille bébés par an
alors que l'allemagne se redresser
moi je crois quand même que c'est le
faire d enfance est le seul où le signe
de la vitalité d'un pc le signe que les
habitants de ce pays croient encore en
leur propre avenir et en l'avenir de la
nation donc voilà c'est le signe à mon
avis là d'un pays a pâti qu'il ya une
récente enquête du du cevipof faite par
le cros banque est parue
je crois la semaine dernière qui parlait
d'un pays naufragés ou près de la moitié
des français ne se reconnaissait plus
dans la nation il disait finalement on
n'est plus un archipel mais on est un
pays en voie de désintégration je crois
que voilà ça s'inscrit aussi
là dedans et
les gens ne se reconnaissent plus dans
quelque chose qui les transcende et sont
donc pas forcément un site et voilà à
croire en à venir et faire des enfants
c'est croire en l'avenir
qu'est ce qui s'est passé nicolas
barrère votre avis qui peut expliquer ce
décrochage qui datent pas de l'année
dernière parce que peut-être que si on
s'interroge sur les explications on
pourra trouver des solutions certains
disent que la politique des de l'état
notamment via les allocations familiales
est devenue moins favorable avec
françois hollande à l'elysée peut être
un des facteurs d'explication c'est
incontestablement le décrochage
effectivement correspond à peu près à 7
ce tour de vis qui a été mis à la
politique familiale et c'est vrai que
c'est une évolution qui date maintenant
de alors je pense que aussi d'autres
aspects par exemple la déstabilisation
des classes moyennes après le krach de
2008 2009
très clairement parce que c'est une
évolution qui est pas spécifique à la
france ce qui est ce qui est spécifique
à la france et c'est le pays d'europe
avec l'irlande qui résistaient mieux et
que maintenant on est en train de
rejoindre
on est en train de rejoindre les autres
est ce que c'est un problème oui quand
on regarde un pays comme l'italie
dans la démographie est sinistrée les
jeunes partent et l'italie comme on le
sait c'est un pays où la richesse par
habitant n'a pas bougé depuis
la fin du xxème siècle deux décennies
blanche et ça se voit maintenant très
fortement sur le l'état du pays
donc où le japon est un autre exemple où
la population diminue maintenant assez
vite et haut au japon le la richesse par
habitant de ce maintien que par la
diminution du nombre d'habitants ce qui
est quand même assez à cette
problématique a toutefois relancé cette
folie familiale ou est ce qu'il n'est
pas trop tard
oh non je pense qu'il ya un déséquilibre
parce que vous voyez dans le bon on a un
état providence qui brassent 34% du pib'
et finalement il y avait donc il y à il
ya quatre grandes fonctions une fonction
qui est non discutable absolument qui
est l'indemnisation des accidents du
travail
ça c'est la moindre des choses
évidemment
et avec un système de financement
particulier d'ailleurs intelligent ou
les entreprises qui connaissent le plus
de sinistres sont le plus lourdement
imposés bon ensuite il ya la santé avec
un énorme problème puisque ça absorbe
tous pour cent du pipe pour quelque
chose qui ne marche plus du tout comme
on l'a vu il ya la retraite qui est de
plus en plus lourde et qui n'est plus
financé et puis avec la politique
familiale la politique familiale en fait
on l'a amputé pour combler les trous de
la santé et de la retraite
et finalement c'est un pays qui est en
train d' arbitrer à l'intérieur du
système de protection sociale comme pour
tout le reste des flux en faveur des
vieux contre les jeunes aujourd'hui on
sait que c'est les jeunes qui sont au
chômage chez les jeunes qui sont pauvres
et les jeunes par ailleurs ils sont
moins en moins nombreux et les familles
sont moins en moins aidés et tout cet
argent est déversée notamment dans le
système de retraite donc c'est vrai que
la france est maintenant un pays où les
princes sont les retraités qui ont un
pouvoir d'achat qui est supérieur à
celui des actifs donc il ya eu des
effets très positifs en de la très
grande majorité maintenant on a à peu
près a indiqué la pauvreté pour les plus
de 60 ans et vit
avant c'est très bien mais on l'a fait
au prix quand même de ce qui n'est pas
loin d'être un grand massacre des
familles et des jeunes et là je pense
que on est vraiment allé beaucoup trop
loin et un pays ce qui a été dit un pays
qui ne s'occupent plus ni des familles
nées des jeunes c'est un pays qui n'a
pas de venir et qu'il y est c'est
vraiment maintenant la manière dont
fonctionne la protection sociale c'est
vraiment un système d'arbitrage
systématique au détriment des jeunes et
des familles en faveur des plus âgés qui
n'est pas d'ailleurs sans rappeler les
arbitrages faits par l'état où les
dépenses de fonctionnement sont
favorisés ok moi de m'investir
si vous me permettez cette analogie sur
internet c'est intéressant parce que
c'est toujours intéressant ce qu'on nous
dit
et la façon dont vous votez mais sur
twitter quand on vous pose la question
faut-il prendre des mesures pour enrayer
la baisse de la natalité en france eh
ben c'est non à 57 % alors rien de plus
de 600 votants donc c'est pas un sondage
mais quand même il ya soya sur youtube
qui le dit nous sommes déjà trop
nombreux sur terre
romain faire un enfant dans un monde
pareil c'est purement et simplement
égoïste et puis n'égale sur youtube qui
considère aussi qu'il faut vraiment être
motivé de nos jours pour faire des
enfants vu l'avenir qui se prépare si je
puis dire oui et se mêlent tidianisme
qui ça c'est vraiment le moyen de tuer
un pays c'est ce qu'on a fait dans les
années 30 mais ça et donc ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose qu'il faut casser
avec 100 et puis aussi cette réaction de
mjp le fils le figaro.fr ne faudrait-il
pas parler du nombre d'avortements
également alors le nombre d'avortements
si mes souvenirs sont bons il est à peu
près stable 1,7 environ deux cent mille
par an donc il ya pas eu d'augmentation
substantielle qui pourrait expliquer le
déficit au graphique
non je suis entièrement d'accord avec
avec nicolas baverez et ça montre que
même si la politique familiale a été
catastrophique
j'y reviendrai je crois que c'est plus
profond que ça qu'on a un problème
métaphysique où on ne voit dans les
réactions des auditeurs faire un enfant
dans ce monde là et ils nous disent
c'est c'est être égoïste donc ça montre
qu'il ya eu un manque absolu de cochons
sur l'avenir notamment de la part de la
jeunesse qui est censé faire des enfants
et on l'a dit les arbitrages sont faits
plutôt pour les retraités
c'est vrai que dans un monde qui est
déjà une très grande insécurité
voilà faire un enfant c'est plus
difficile quand le monde
nenê n'est pas sûr et donc si les
arbitrages sont faits pour pour les
retraités et pas pour les jeunes
l'incitation à il n'ya pas d'incitation
joue juste un mot sur les politiques
familiales il ya une dérive je crois
c'est que la politique familiale est
devenue une politique sociale alors que
c'était pas son but
effectivement son but c'était
d'accroître la démographie donc elle
devrait être
voilà pas sous conditions de ressources
parce que l'évolution de ces dernières
années elle est devenue sous condition
de rosser 50 quand on est riche on
considère que quand on est aisé qu'on
considère désormais qu'on a moins besoin
d' aide alors qu'avant on disait mais
avoir des enfants ça coûte cher donc
quelle que soit votre revenu
vous avez la grèce puis c'était assumé
comme quelque chose de bon pour la
nation de de faire des enfants donc moi
je crois qu'il faut revenir là-dessus
refaire de la politique familiale voilà
une politique nataliste tout simplement
peut-être l'assortir d'une dimension de
préférence nationale puisque si l'idée
c'est de bâtir l'avenir du pays
elle devrait être résorbé préau
prioritairement à mon avis aux nationaux
je pense qu'on pourrait effectivement
commencé par là pour pour
à citer les gens à faire à faire des
enfants
il ya une question de claudius 15 sur
lefigaro.fr qui je voue retransmet
alexandre pour combler le déficit des
naissances des naissances ne faudrait-il
pas augmenter l'immigration
oui j'allais y venir ça a été la grande
idée de l'europe il y avait un rapport
là dessus avec les dés en plus que ça
allait permettre de financer nos
politiques sociales moi je suis pas sûr
que ça creuse le déficit le déficit
budgétaire puisque les gens quand ils
viennent ici certes ça une partie de
travail mais pas tous et puis c'est ça
aussi un coût un coup en matière de
santé un coup en matière d'éducation un
coup hélas en matière de sécurité donc
ça me paraît être un raisonnement
complètement fou et qui est propre à
alimenter les thèses du rock du grand
remplacement un pays vieillissant qui se
meurt et qui serait régénéré par par
l'immigration
si on veut faire monter non pas même
l'extrême droite mais mais l'ultra
droite je crois que on ne peut pas s'y
prendre autrement que que voilà on
menant une politique comme celle ci en
expliquant qu'il faudrait finalement
remplacé la population française par par
des émules
pourtant c'est un choix qui est presque
assumée par d'autres pays qui ont une
démographie vieillissante comme
l'allemagne par exemple nicolas baverez
qui qui dit ben oui nous avons besoin
d'immigration alors l'allemagne le fait
mais le fait de manière extrêmement
contrôlée il ya d'autres pays qui font
ce choix qui sont des pays qui
continuent à être des pays de peuplement
comme le le canada ou la nouvelle
zélande mais c'est strictement ces
strips tu sais c'est assez encadrée et
pour la france c'est que c'est une bonne
idée ou pas bon je pense pas du tout
effectivement que ce soit là aujourd'hui
la priorité la priorité comme on l'a dit
c'est un pays qui ne sait plus ni ce
qu'il est ni où il est ni ce qu'il veut
ni où il va
et donc c'est ça qu'il faut arriver à
remettre d'aplomb et
et c'est un peu ce qu'ils avaient la
même perte de sens qu'on avait eu dans
les années 30 puis à partir de 1945
après tout les drames de l'occupation de
la guerre civile de le
ensuite et puis évidemment le à l'ombre
de la débâcle et française sont dit
qu'ils allaient reconstruire leur pays
qu'ils allaient le reconstruire pour
avoir un pays qu'il redevienne un pays
qui compte dans le monde et aujourd'hui
c'est ça la priorité est donc il faut le
faire avec et c'est la meilleure manière
de redonner aux français confiance en
eux mêmes pour qu'ensuite y compris que
qu'ils aient des enfants est par
ailleurs dans un monde qui est quand
même un monde effectivement très
incertain très compliqué il faut
évidemment aider les familles d'ailleurs
ce qui est intéressant de voir c'est que
l'allemagne où des pays comme la russie
qui ont des dons devraient des problème
démographique considérable se sont mis
alors qu'il n'avait pas de politique
familiale se sont mis à en développer
des politiques familiales assez
ambitieuse au moment où la france qui en
avait une qui fonctionnait démanteler la
sienne 1 ce qui est quand même ce qui
est quand même vraiment dommage là
quelques commentaires pour terminer
cette émission celui des dieux hindous
sur lefigaro.fr qui nous dit que il lui
semble que la france a connu d'autres
périodes de dénatalité effectivement
nicolas barry vient d'en parler
notamment en particulier plutôt dans
l'entre-deux-guerres
donc après la première guerre mondiale
sonia sur youtube j'ai 30 ans et je n'ai
toujours pas d'enfant
je n'ai pas envie de leur laisser un
avenir sombre et comme je ne veux pas
terminer cette émission sur une note
aussi peu enthousiasmant c'est chardons
bleus qui aura le mot de la fin à lons
la vie n'est pas si moche en france et
dans le monde
haut les coeurs merci beaucoup de nous
avoir suivis et à demain
[Musique]